peu
[Applaudissements]
il revient à ma mémoire des souvenirs
familier
je revois ma blouse noire lorsque
j'étais écolier sur le chemin de l'école
je chantais la plaine voire des romances
sans parole via you chanson
d'autres foires
douce france
cher pays de mon enfance
[Musique]
percée de tendre insouciance
j'étais gardez donc
[Musique]
mon village
je recherchais aux maisons aux sages
tous les enfants de mon âge je partager
mon bonheur
[Musique]
oui je t'ai
je te donne ce prêt
oui je t'aime
dans la shoah ou la douleur
frans
on ne se prend cher pays de mon enfance
bercée de prendre insouciance
j'ai des gars avait dans mon coeur
j'ai connu des paysages des soleils
merveilleux au cours de lointains
voyages tout là-bas tout d'autres cieux
mes bouquins je leur préfère mon ciel
bleu
mon horizon magourou de ma rivière ma
prairies et ma maison
[Musique]
cher pays de mon enfance
percée de tendre insouciant
je sais garder dans mon coeur
oh
mon village au clocher ou maison sage ou
les enfants de mon âge
[Musique]
repartager mon bonheur
oh
oui je t'ai
et je te donne ce prêt
oui je t'aime
dans la joie ou la douleur
nous pensons gpi des bons enfants
r ce n'est pas grâce aux sciences
j'étais garder dans mon coeur
goethe également de nom
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle est à toi cette chanson toi
l'auvergnat qui sans façons m'as donné
quatre bouts de bois quand dans ma vie
il faisait froid
toi qui m'as donnait du feu quand
les copains et les coquins
tous les gens bien intentionnés mme
avait fermé la porte au nez
ce n'était rien qu'un feu de bois
mais il m'avait chauffer leur corps et
dans mon ami brûle encore à la manière
d'un feu de joie
doisneau bernard quand tu mourras quand
le prof mode emporte à il te conduise à
travers ciel
opel qu'elle même elle est à toi cette
chanson toi l'hôtesse est dû sans doute
façon m'a donné quatre bouts ne pas nous
quand dans ma vie il faisait faire
toi qui m'ouvre ict a eu chaud car tous
les croquants télécom quand les gens
bien intentionnés s'amusait à me voir je
ne
ce n'était rien qu'un peu de pain
mais si ma fait chauffer le corps est
dans mon coeur me brûle en tout cas à la
manière d'un grand fest
toi l'hôtesse quand tu mourras quand le
prof m'emporte a conduit à travers ciel
au père éternel elle est à toi cette
chanson toi les denrées qui sans façon
le nerf mal eux
ma souris lorsque les gendarmes m'ont
peu
toi qui n'a pas applaudi quand les
copains et les coquins
tous les gens bien intentionnés riet de
m'avoir emmené ce n'était rien
qu'un peu de miel
mais s'il m'a fait chauffer le corps est
dans mon ami brûle encore à la manière
d'un grand soleil toi l'étranger quand
tu mourras quand le croque mort tant qu
tu as dû te conduise à travers ciel
opère interne heures
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président
je vous fais une lettre que vous lirez
peut-être si vous avez le temps je viens
de recevoir mes papiers militaires pour
partir à la guerre
avant mercredi soir
monsieur
le président je ne veux pas la faire je
ne suis pas sur terre pour tuer des
pauvres jours c'est pas pour vous
franchement il faut que je vous dise
ma décision est prise je mentais
déshérités
[Musique]
depuis que je suis née
mon père je
vu partir mes frères
[Musique]
mes enfants ma mère a tant souffert
m
sa tombe
ce manque que des bons
et ce matin
quand j'étais
le prisonnier
un bonnet
ma femme rom m'a volé
nam et touchait repasser demain de bon
matin je fermerai
map en trop
année
menteur j'irai sur
chemin
je m'en dire
avis sur leur hôte la france
de bretagne en top
et je dire
refuser d'obéir
refus
la peur
n'allez pas
la gueule
refusé
de par nature si le pôle
bonsoir
vous vous êtes bons apôtres monsieur
le président si vous me poursuivez
rêvait
gros joindra
que je ne
pas
d'armes et qu'ils pourront tirer
[Rires]
[Musique]
on
et
je suis passionné
m
[Musique]
m o
du temps
m
allez
[Musique]
voir les collections les
et c'est fatigant
intense à fait certain temps les
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
quand j'ai teint
sanguin
et là quand tu ne viendras
elle commande toujours la voiture qui
gagné
le rallye le plus connu
mais leur plan les pas sur lui
[Applaudissements]
gaza plus
et il est tellement pas lui
elles vont pas tout seul mais dangereux
pour tout con
regardez
la politique
sa volée
moi tu
bakou
jamais
non
je l'espère
[Applaudissements]
leur esprit s'épanouissent que c'est bon
quand l'existence est compliqué
dans la vie
elle s'ennuie
dans la mirada sait sur qui compter coli
tous
tant que
j'apprendrai mois
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
ma vie
[Musique]
et c'est pour
je ne
les regrets dans les
[Musique]
table
la pensée
[Musique]
tél
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
notre pari à bello dépasse les autos
mais l'autre à paris on dépasse les
taxis paris
[Musique]
passez les autos
un seul type
place des pets enrouleur pas
la spli chillon ou le pas
la bastille est assiégé
et la république et on
angers dans paris à vélo on dépasse les
autos ont nommé lors d'un pari on n'est
pas seuls et tactique
à ce jour
les taxis
l'agent voudraient se mettre au vert
le père arrive de kanter
attendre
la démo et relie berlin
paris un péno
mais pas seul et surtout la paix
dans paris on dépasse les pratiques
paris
à paris
[Musique]
et que toutes les filles disent y
habitent au casino de paris way en a qui
pensent que le champagne sans des
gargouilles de notre dame et qu'entre
deux alka 16h11
la culotte en l'air les entend on
tu sais
qu'on aime
[Musique]
à temps
ma voix
j'habite en prend
et la france s'est pas
tout ce qu'on dit si les français se
plaignent parfois
la gueule
le boire cet enfant
kylie à paris mais la france est aussi
ouias temps
utile y en a qui pensent que notre
musique balance comme une bière de
munich que toutes nos danseuses en la
classe mais swing à côté de leurs
godasses y en a qui disent qu'ils un
sûrement de trois cafés par habitant que
nos rythmique son des fanfares long sur
j'ai des chansons à boire
les entend on
qu'en france il n'y a pas
musicien
mais voilà
j'habite enfants
la france
c'est pas du tout ce qu'on dit si les
français simple
ce n'est pas moi
la gueule
cet enfant
il y a
mais la france c'est rossi
bouya blanc même
y en a qui pense et c'est certain que
les français se défendent bien
toutes les filles sont là pour le dire
on les fait mourir de plaisir à les
entendre entre
[Musique]
il faut
à bien
c'est pourquoi
[Musique]
enfants
et
beaucoup
[Musique]
sia le rêve d'habiter chez moi
qui
de quoi c'est pourquoi j'appuie comprend
et
c'est beau
[Musique]
j'étais chez moi
c'est qui
de quoi
des enfants
kylie à paris
mais la france c'est 2
où il ya quand même ça
quand millions
uti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jour de gloire
les guitares les tendeurs
[Musique]
était défoncée
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
et la motion ou trottoirs
du
je peux plus
ce triptyque
[Musique]
m
la peau
[Musique]
patrick le lay
carrez
j
genre
[Musique]
lapoutroie toi tu
k
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sauf le baby ce leader
[Musique]
mickey
enfin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
facebook mais le prix peut booster
70e
ben alors
[Musique]
je
se montrer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]